I put some lube on and got him on his
knees they had a hearing in the senate
about the book Banning and what mostly
about Florida right what Florida has
done with book bags so one of our true
National Treasures Senator John Kennedy
from Louisiana he then decided to read
out of one of the books that has been
banned here in Florida and you tell me
if you think that these are words that a
child should hear in third or fourth
grade from a state employee take a look
let's take
two books that have been much discussed
um
the first one is called
all boys aren't blue
and I will quote from it
I put some lube on and got him on his
knees
and I began to slide into him from
behind
I pulled out of him and kissed him while
he masturbated
he asked me to turn over while he
slipped a condom on himself
this was my ass and I was struggling to
imagine someone inside me
he got on top and slowly inserted
himself into me
it was the worst pain I think I have
ever felt in my life
eventually I felt a mix of pleasure with
the pain
close quote all boys aren't blue
the second is a another much discuss
book
I'm sure you're familiar with it it's
called genderqueer
okay
let me read an excerpt from that quote
I got a new strap strap-on harness today
I can't wait to put it on you
it will fit my favorite dildo perfectly
you're going to look so hot
I can't wait to have your in my
mouth
I'm going to give you the of
your life then I want you inside of me
end quote
now
Mr secretary
what are you asking us to do
are you suggesting
that only Librarians should decide
whether the two books
that I just referenced
should be available to kids
is that what you're saying no okay tell
me what you're saying well
first of all there's this don't give me
a speech tell me what you're asking me
to do with all due respect Center the
words you spoke are disturbing
especially coming out of your mouth is
very disturbing but what I would also
tell you that we're not advocating for
kids to report to Senator Bookers what
are you advocating for we are advocating
for
parents random parents not to have the
ability under the guise of keeping kids
safe to try and challenge the world view
of every single manner on these issues
you're getting conceptual games I might
get a conception you are yes you are
because you I want to know what you're
recommending all right first off we
should have just shown you that John
Kennedy clip completely out of context
at the beginning of the show and that I
just should have walked off the set but
that's that's one thing I'm not even
sure who that person is that he's
talking to random parents they're not
random parents they are parents who have
kids at these schools who are often on
school boards who are upset about that
so again everyone knows everyone knows
that what Ron DeSantis has done here in
Florida is right and it is the model and
the blueprint for what should be
happening across the country
oh